hello everyone and welcome to the second
match between Magnus Carlsen and Bing
Liron yesterday Magnus won Game six it
was a blitz game and the with that game
he won the match and now Dean needs to
retaliate in this match the force match
three and hopefully reached the finals
of the twenty20 chest bull masters
however this is a position from Game one
and already in Game one something
interesting happened I decided to only
show you the position from Game one and
then we're gonna cover game three
actually but yeah yeah this is the
position from game one and in this
position after rook the c8 being replied
with Queen to b3 he offer the Queen
trade and he wants to escort his pawn up
the board however this loses the game
terribly and now I feel free to pause
the video and find a win for Magnus well
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting the well
fairly simple tactic and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to c1 check somehow being missed
this and well he was in this position
after work to see one unmoved 66 that
Dingley resigned game one point is that
you're in check and you have nothing if
you capture the rook then you lose the
Queen and if you don't if you just move
the king with a king g2 then just Queen
captures and b1 and it's well just the
game over you are up up a full rook and
White has no counter play so that's what
happens in Game one in Game two
where Magnus had the white pieces that
game was a draw and now we go into Game
three
we're being again has the white pieces
and he first needs to equalize to just
get back into this match and then
hopefully win it the force match three
so let's see what happens ding sticks to
his English opening so he goes for c4 we
have a 5 by Magnus and now g3 we have d5
at the very early d5 very very popular
we have see captures Queen captures now
attacking the rook on each one and 90 to
f3 now blocking and you have to be very
careful not to overextend with the pawn
since 93 just makes it a very annoying
position for black you still have to
keep an eye on your pawn then the other
night comes after you and after you move
attack let's say the knight then III and
you all you've done basically is helped
white to develop so after night if
with Knight to c6 and now Knight to c3
pushes Carlson's King back a queen back
we have Queen back all the way to d8 and
Bishop the g2 now is ready to castle we
have Knight f6 and here comes castles
and now this position has been reached
before plenty of times the Bishop to c5
is a is the main move here in this
position however Magnus plays h6 and h6
is a new move in the position so already
as of move seven we have a completely
new game so then continues with d3 it
doesn't allow for at any point and also
prepares efore at some point Bishop to
d6 now by Magnus still not going for
Bishop to c5 he has some different ideas
we have a three and taking away the the
be for square from blacks pieces
preparing before Bishop to b2 to grab
hold of this diagonal with the bishop
but now a5 Magnus doesn't allow before
so b3 it's the way things are done
we have castles and now Bishop to b2 so
ding feein Karos both of his bishops and
he is very happy now with the white
pieces we have worked eh by Magnus again
looking at that he for a four push we
have looked a c1 and now first bishop to
f5 so just continuing development with
h3 and Queen to d7 now preparing to
capture on an h3 here so King h2 ding
defends it and now Knight to d4 and here
Magnus says that he is in fact very
happy even though he has the black
pieces our point is if the knight is
captured then you harass this Knight you
kick it away and this leaves white with
a backwards e to point which will be a
target as you will not be able to push
it or you could like play some like
Knight to a4 and then push efore but
being decides against this so instead
Knight back to d2 by ding and here
c6 by Magnus taking away these squares
from the white knight and now III
attacking the knight Knight b5 as c6
prepared there as well
we have ninth chapter see characters and
now the b7 pawn is nicely protected and
the Magnus gets the say the open C file
for his rooks if needed so Knight to f3
now preparing ideas like d4 or or maybe
e4 and e4 later
now rook 8 d8 still d3 the backward
spawn so Carlsen decides to put his
forces towards the D pawn here we have e
for biding pushing the bishop back
Bishop to e6 and now the e5 pawn can be
captured however Magnus will recapture
the point afterwards
so here ding goes for Bishop captures
captures captures and now Queen to d6
with a double attack and here Magnus
said ok I will lose a pawn in the center
and I will allow you to have this past
the D pawn however I will have the
majority on the Queen side and I will do
my best to create a passed pawn on the
Queen side so here F for being defends
the night and now Queen captures on a3
and now the b3 pawn is also under attack
and Magnus ding could defend it would
sound like rook the b1 but he prefers a
more active plan he plays d4 he
sacrifices the b3 pawn to get the d5 in
and then he really starts pushing his
passport
so here Magnus goes for it Bishop
captures and b3 he says I'm gonna be
faster on the Queen side as he had he
now has two connected passed pawns on
the Queen side against the Kings massive
Center so we have Queen to d3 now the
bishop cannot move as the Queen hangs on
a 3 so Queen to b4 and now d5 so dink
got what he wanted he created the past D
pawn and it's a very strong pawn so all
do you all you have to do basically is
to push it so here
rook the c8 Magnus offers a trade of
rooks but now these six as Magnus left
the d6 square undefended now Magnus goes
back rooks C to D it as now there's a
double attack on the night here on the
pawn obviously and here d7 so here the
rook is under attack what do you do here
d7 in fact loses the game 14 however you
need to feel you need to pause the video
and define the winning move for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that it is
much needed to give up a piece but only
temporarily and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's night
capture Sandies
and just give up the night and that wins
the game very very simple so being
captured the night but now comes the
Bishop to c4 just attacking the Queen
and the rook and here you don't have a
lot like if you decide you could decide
to give up the exchange here with rook
captures on c4 and it kind of does make
sense and Queen d5 to keep an eye on the
night but then Queen e7 with a double
attack and now after the rook defends
that rook to d1 it seems like white was
able to defend he has two pieces for the
rook however black has the past C pawn
so C 3 and the white will not be able to
hold on to the night you cannot move it
since you lose the Queen so here it
doesn't really matter
a5 c2 and the rook now must leave the D
file it's a Brooke c1 and now we simply
capture here and after everything is
traded off it's just a rook to works
against the rook and Bishop with black
being up upon but the two connected
passed pawns on the Queen side are
completely winning so this is it's not
even close to try something like this so
after Bishop to c4 ding instead played
Queen to d1
he says okay you can have that I'm going
to defend my knight over here but Magnus
doesn't capture it Magnus instead just
goes Queen to e7 and it was in this
position that Dingley ran resigned the
game and as he already lost game 1 this
means that he loses match 2 and by
losing match 1 he now lost the match
completely and magnus carlsen is the
first finalist of the 2020 testable
masters and he awaits his opponent which
will be the victor of the match he
anypony versus a new Giri here we resign
because your rook is still under attack
and of course you will lose the piece
here so let's say you play rook to f2
just rope capture son d7 and there's not
much to be done here the Queen is under
attack once you move it just a 4 and
it's well not not even not even playable
for white yes you didn't lose a piece or
anything it's still two rooks white the
rooks black and both players have a
bishop but black is up two points and
those are three points that you can push
here and the Dean of course knows that
you cannot hold this against Magnus
so after Queen t7 being resigned and
Magnus Carlsen is the first finalist of
the 22
chasuble masters so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Dan jank
Cameron Harrison Alexandra's puppies
Rakesh Kumar Rajan and John Logan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the twenty20
chasuble masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
want to see something cool - check the
first link in the description below see
you soon